so what is it that they're celebrating
as far as you can tell
they think that a fascist or a racist
got the violence against him that he
deserved
yeah but i don't believe that you know i
don't believe that's what they're
celebrating
because i don't think i don't think
they're that good
i think they're celebrating watching
some poor son of a [__] get hurt
and that that satisfies something
unbelievably dark in their souls like
the desire to burn the desire to burn
down buildings the desire to melt cars
the desire for the whole goddamn thing
to go up in flames because they're
resentful and bitter
because we can't take these things at
face value right it's like no no you
don't understand you're smiling and
laughing while someone just got his
teeth kicked in no trial no jury
no defense
he's on the ground he's mobbed by
by overwhelming force
and you're celebrating that and you're
telling me that's because of your
virtues
it's like i don't think so
[Music]
hello everyone
i'm pleased today to have with me
someone i've wanted to talk to for a
long time mr andy no andy is a
journalist best known for reporting on
american antifa
he's an editor at large at the
post-millennial which has recently been
under attack by
left-wing radicals i would say who have
uh
sought to have the advertisers drop the
post-millennial as a
and deprive and depriving them of their
source of revenue and consequence he's
written reports for the new york post
newsweek and other media major media
outlets he drew national attention when
he was beaten and hurt very badly by
antifa thugs on the streets of portland
in the summer of 2019
his february 2021 book unmasked inside
antifa's radical plan to destroy
democracy was a new york times
bestseller and quite a gripping read i
might add andy had to leave the us
because of concerns for his safety and
is currently residing in the uk
hey andy so nice to see you we haven't
met before i don't think having my
memories a bit spotty and but i don't
think we've ever met
is that true correct actually no no no
professor we have when you were on your
tour and you were in portland on the
door
that was where there were some of the
largest demonstrations against you and
backstage uh i interviewed you for my
podcast very very briefly
ah sorry i'm sorry i've
that hasn't managed to lodge itself in
my memory unfortunately although i do
remember that there were
protests in portland that was pretty
much it for protests you know on that
whole tour so but of course you know
they would be in portland and
they weren't against me either they were
against who people wished i was so that
they could protest me really
so all right so
i've been going through distinction
yes it is an important distinction
because you know a lot a lot of our ire
is reserved for our imaginary enemies
and so that's certainly something that
we could delve into a little bit with
regards to antifa so let's go there
right away so i was talking to a number
of influential democrats this week about
antifa and about january 6th okay and so
so imagine that an outside observer like
a canadian might look at the united
states and think well you know the
radical left has
portland and minneapolis and that's
pretty damn ugly and then the radical
right has january 6 and that's pretty
ugly and you know maybe you could draw
some kind of equivalency between the two
and maybe not but i think you could at
least make a reasonable initial case for
something like that january 6 had a lot
of symbolic weight if nothing else and
and certainly did frighten people very
badly but when i was talking to these
democrats about antifa and the riots you
know their attitude is sort of
well there's there's always been
riots and race riots in the united
states throughout its entire history so
in some sense it's really nothing out of
the ordinary and besides antifa doesn't
really exist and so
i'd like you to address if you would
both of those
points and i should point out too these
are reasonable people making these
points these aren't radical leftists
these are people who are trying hard to
pull the democratic party towards a
moderate center and who are very
suspicious of the radical leftists
especially the grip they have on the
education system so
they're good faith players and still
and oh the other thing they said to me
was that they believed it was
intellectually dishonest to draw a
parallel between portland and
minneapolis and january 6th uh making
the case that what happened on january 6
was much much worse like in a in a
category of its own and they justified
that by referring to the fact that it
was direct assault on the capitol
building you know and and
and and that there was presidential
ambivalence about bringing that to a
halt so that's a rat's nest so you know
you want to wade in
yes professor so i think uh
let's say for good faith engagement from
the left um i
completely understand why there would be
this perception that
antifa is a myth or um doesn't really
exist
because that's the propaganda that
the public said from
the legacy media and broadcast and in
print day in and day out certainly since
trump was elected it's an entirely
different story though when you are on
the ground as i have been for years and
you see that militancy face to face and
when you see it the
the organization or aspect of it is
undeniable that's what initially sparked
my curiosity because in portland where
i'm from
when the election results in 2016
november were announced
tens of thousands of people took to the
streets and within that there was a an
organized element of people dressed in
the same uniforms at that time it was
unusual to cover your face and they had
weapons in in a very strategic way
uh smash and move on smash and move on
cars
businesses
build buildings start fires run
um
so it was from there that sparked my
interest in wanting to learn more about
what looks like an organized militia or
paramilitary
so
with that out of the way though um i
think the press because of its
compromise nature and generally being
biased a lot they have turned a blind
eye to the
evidence that shows that there's in
depending on where you are there's an
organized organizational structure to
antifa
and um the statement that biden said
infamously at one of the debates uh last
year antifa is an idea that statement in
itself is true um but it's not the it's
not the complete statement you have
i think
one way to explain it that people can
understand perhaps more easily is its
analogous to
the worldwide uh jihadist phenomenon in
that you can have people who are actual
members of organizations like boko haram
or ayas or al-qaeda
or any of these other jihadist groups
but you have people as well who are
sympathetic to the ideology and act on
it and in that regard i think you can
think of
the contemporary manifestations of
anti-fun in
in the united states canada in western
countries
along the same lines you can have people
who had self-identify in and simply all
they do is go to these
protests or riots based on flyers you
see online then you have actual cells
that operate such as rose city antifa
which is an organized group you can go
on their website and look at the q a and
they actually have one of the questions
is how do i join and they say that
currently membership is closed
so there's that and in my book i publish
some of the primary documents of the
curriculum from rose city antifa which
is actually one of the cells that's part
of a network called um the torch antifa
network and they have cells in other
cities
so from you know it's kind of all of the
above it's ideology it's um
uh
un horizontally organized it's
disorganized it's
also highly organized in some cases
so it's because of that um
lack of centralized hierarchical
authority that makes it easy for those
who want to obfuscate and confuse the
public about it because they can point
and say well you know there's no single
leader who's the leadership show me the
leadership because
there is no single
um person who's heading everything
then the response is well that's
evidence that they don't exist um you
know yeah okay so this is this is a real
problem conceptually right i mean and
let's think about it to begin with as a
problem that we all face instead of a
political problem emanating either from
the left or the right
okay because i think there's a deeper
problem here that isn't exactly
partisan and we'll get into the partisan
element of it later
so imagine first of all
okay so i i assume that the description
you gave would be the one that you gave
is that okay so what we have here is we
have some actual organizations let's
focus on rose city and antifa
and
but but it's a radically distributed
organization
and we don't even know how radically
distributed and it's almost impossible
to identify its core members or even to
define what core membership might be now
you you did point to rose city antifa
but if i said for example how many other
antifa groups are there that have an
identifiable organizational strategy
that's akin to rose city antifa how many
do you
do do you have any sense of that
just like just a few dozen there aren't
very many but the thing is many they
they they close and then they spring up
as new ad hoc groups under different
names but that's really the same
okay a few dozen so that's real
interesting so that's like let's say 24.
just let's let's make this concrete
because i think it'll be interesting to
do so
so
in that 24 how many people do you think
are core
involved
in each group do you think it's like
five is it three is it ten
like real hardcore people who are
devoting their time to this you know
like like maybe they're unemployed that
would be a real shock and it's their
full-time job
something like that how many people
across the entirety of the united states
uh base if most of them let's say we're
averaging around the same size as rose
city antifa then i would say in total
we're looking at below a thousand people
in
in across the entire united states so
hundreds
which is you know
in the scheme of things and for the
scale that's a rel that's a very small
number
yeah well it's look it's so small that
you could say that it's and i'm not
saying this
but it's so small that you could say
that it's non-existent right because
it's one in three hundred thousand if
it's the us it's it's such a tiny
minority of people that they barely
exist but what that points to is
something actually that minimizing it in
that manner actually points to something
far more sinister because what it means
is that
under a thousand committed people can
radically destabilize whole cities and
pose a threat to the integrity of entire
culture not not not least by
fostering polarization and and the
degeneration of the political scheme
that comes along with that
and so that's a real danger for all of
us particularly if it's the case that
groups like that can multiply their
power by pulling other you know
semi-attached and maybe not so violent
or even extremist people in on the basis
of their empathy
exactly uh
concentric circles probably is a good
way to explain it uh
what you asked me the concrete number of
how many people are actually core in
terms of um
involved in the organizing the planning
attending meetings or trainings
like as you said almost
almost non-existent given the the
population side of the u.s however um
the the larger concentric circle is of
their sympathizers and i think the role
of the press since particularly
i would say since the election of trump
helped really to mainstream the
so-called antifa ideology it
put um day in and day out for the entire
world that
this belief that america had elected a
fascist president under trump that we
were experiencing a regime change that
there would be people
there would be genocide
and
on the face i mean these ideas are
these
accusations are so outrageous and
i would say laughable
but people genuinely believe that you
know go back five years remember like
this
yeah i know they believe that
yeah well they're feeling the same way
about trump running again you know that
fear is definitely there and i think
it's probably even higher than it was at
least
it's higher than it was in some ways
among the same people
and so because they think well he didn't
manage to establish an authoritarian
state this time but you know just wait
we're we'll see what happens if he gets
power a second time it might be the last
election the united states ever has but
think about what this means so because i
also i talk to people on the left a lot
most of them are moderate
um the you know the extreme left types
they generally won't talk to me but um
although i would talk to them if i had
found someone who was credible and and
interesting to talk to and who was
willing to um what that means is think
about the conceptual problem that we're
faced with now so
the people on the left can point to the
right and say well what about your
extremists
and the people on the right can say well
there's hardly any of them there's like
they basically don't exist
and
and in some sense that's genuinely true
and on the left it's the same thing it's
like it's hardly anybody at all it's
under a thousand people committed to
this
but they can cause a tremendous amount
of trouble and so
then the left can point to the people on
the right who are extreme and say well
look at your extremists and what they do
and then the right can point to the
people on the left and say look at your
extremists and what they do and we don't
know how dangerous they are and what
happens if they get out of control and
get the upper hand and how much
protection do we have to you know uh uh
wall ourselves in with in order to make
sure that doesn't happen and then the
fact of those extremists mean that each
side can demonize the other by pointing
to the worst and then everybody gets out
of control and so and it's not obvious
at all how to deal with that uh lying
certainly
lying about it certainly complicates the
situation tremendously right if there's
any deceit in the press coverage and so
forth and
so but
okay so so that's a problem a conceptual
problem and then
why do you think that legacy media so to
speak
is so light-handed in its treatment of
antifa given the tremendous damage
and and loss of life and violence for
that matter that the riots that antifa
in some sense are central to has caused
like if you had to play devil's advocate
what's motivating them to minimize this
um
establishment journalists were entirely
uniform and and committed to their goal
in opposing trump and
many of them felt that it was their
duty and obligation to
um
violate some ethical standards because
we were living in such unprecedented
times with trump
in the executive office that he needed
to be
resisted by any means necessary isn't
that always the justification for
ethical violations
isn't that always the rationalization
it's like well this isn't i wouldn't
normally do this but this is an
exceptional case and so not only is it
justified for me to violate my ethical
standards it's actually demanded of me
and so
that seems to me to be an argument i can
understand the argument you know because
well hey maybe we're faced with an
emergency we're going to see a hell of a
lot of that by the way with climate
change
like a lot so it's coming in a big way
and so well if the emergency is large
enough don't we get to violate our own
principles and well you're a journalist
let me ask you a question do you can you
recall a time
and this is a real serious question man
can you recall a time where you thought
the stakes were high enough so that you
violated your journalistic integrity
that's i appreciate the question
so i've covered uh dozens of uh violent
protests and riots where i witnessed
people being
assaulted
i've always
i don't intervene in those instances
uh i try to record a photograph but when
you see for example a mob of people
beating somebody and it doesn't matter
for me the political creation of who
that mob is
i feel sort of as a human as a citizen
i should at least just
intervene in some way
um
that's something that i've struggled
with a lot
okay so you okay so you said you said
that you don't intervene now in your
book
there the account of your severe beating
um i i looked up some press coverage of
that and and i believe this was in your
book as well that while you were being
assaulted so badly there were press
there and they did nothing to intervene
they were just recording and and taking
snapshots and video and so forth and
and
you know in the book that sounds like
that they're derelict in their duties
and maybe
in particular because you're also a
journalist and maybe that you know maybe
there's a special category there but
and then also as a journalist if you are
recording it's like you're putting the
whole above the part in some sense right
because you think you're
you're journalistic
it's demanded of you because of your
journalistic integrity to record and not
to intervene
but but you said you you feel the pull
on your conscience about that so how do
you how is it that you've
learned to live without it what makes
you think that you made the right
decision doing what you've done and
maybe you don't know maybe you know
i'm not entirely sure if i made the
right decision unfortunately i haven't
been like right next to somebody who was
on the
nearly getting killed i think
for that type of instance it's very
clear that that that there's a demand
for an obligation for an intimate
intervention so that somebody's not
murdered
um for me
i mean you're also not a police officer
and and you're not armed and i don't
imagine you're trained in in street
fighting or that sort of thing so
in some sense
you know fools jump in where angels fear
to tread and two people beat to death
isn't really an improvement over one and
so i'm not saying that like leonard
cohen that canadian songwriter said
there's no decent place to stand in a
massacre you know sometimes you're in a
situation where anything you do is bad
because the situation is so terrible so
okay so you've had moral qualms about
how
how apart from the action you should be
under those situations what about like
you're obviously not very happy with
what's happening about antifa and you're
on the ground also as opposed i would
say to these journalists who are
minimizing what antifa is doing they're
much more up in the air in some sense
right so you're down in the trenches to
the point where you're getting beat up
for it and then i would say the people
who aren't doing that and reporting on
it they've got one form of blinders on
because they're not seeing what's
actually happening but in some sense the
risk for you and your integrity is that
you you have the opposite problem you're
so damn involved you're watching
buildings burn you're watching cars melt
you're watching people be assaulted and
being assaulted yourself that
how do you protect yourself against the
possibility that you're exaggerating the
threat because
you you know your sample is up biased
you're in the middle of the damn riots
all the time
yeah i think that's a fair question and
it's a
criticism
i
though the instances of ultra violence
that i've seen and i've written about
and recorded video for um
those are anecdotes that are important
um but they're not the full
story and in my
the purpose of writing
unmasked my book was
to shed light really on the ideology
that i think is
is ultimately much much more dangerous
than these instances of violence that
um lead to um people getting seriously
injured or or killed in that um
i think it's it's a theme and a subject
that you've discussed before in your
speeches and your writings professor
it's about
um this belief that
for
pursuing this justice racial justice
anti-racism whatever name they want to
give
they believe that
no no act that they can make can never
go too far
and that's sort of the
oh isn't that a lovely thing wouldn't
that be a lovely thing to have on your
side so imagine that
you're so virtuous
in your pursuits
that you are now entitled to do
absolutely anything to anyone whenever
you want
i mean if you if you if you have that
kind of cognitive structure i mean first
of all you're not very self-reflective
it's like do i really think that i'm so
ethical that i can give myself a free
hand to do anything
and so i'm increasingly skeptical about
large-scale ethical claims of that sort
you know well this is so important that
well that what exactly
well it depends on how important it is
and well we could climate change a good
example of that well if it's the
ultimate environmental catastrophe
everywhere and it's going to happen
within 20 years then
well
we should do everything
well okay let's get detailed about this
does that mean we get to beat up andy no
if he's not that happy about climate
change well he's just one guy you know
and it's a planet we're talking about
here you know and that's independent in
some sense of whether there are
warranted concerns on the environmental
front i know there are like the oceans
are overfished for example that's not a
good thing it's stupid we should stop
doing it but it's this moral license
that goes along with this claim to
virtue that really scares the hell out
of me and it's also the fact that you
can instantly demonize your enemies
because if you're so virtuous that
everything is justified then anyone who
opposes you is virtually satan
themselves
yes i've seen this with my own eyes this
demonization dehumanization one of the
really shocking things i witnessed last
year at the beginning of the riots i was
undercover so
again i couldn't i couldn't intervene
because if i did it would potentially
blow my cover and i could get seriously
injured or killed but um this wasn't it
anime days after george floyd had died
and the writing had not at that point
spread outside of minneapolis there was
a man that was targeted by the mob he
was accused of being
right wing i whatever accusation is true
or false i don't know but he was beaten
up uh they got him on the ground and
then one of them with glee
uh
rushed at his head and and kicked his
teeth in and
you you could actually see the teeth on
the ground
and what do you mean by with what do you
mean by with glee why that phrase
the crowd around him celebrated that act
was calling this person a fascist
and
was happy that he was was
he was crying and how and how could you
tell the how could you tell they were
happy what exactly were they doing
they had smiles on their faces as they
were looking at this bleeding person on
the ground
yeah well it's hard to see it's hard to
see exactly what would you it's hard to
see exactly what moral claim would
justify that smile
so what do you think's really going on
there just out of curiosity you watched
it right up close
so what are those people celebrating
like what it what is it in them that's
responding to that well you said with
glee you know that that that's a very
specific word
so what is it that they're celebrating
as far as you can tell
they think that a fascist or a racist
got the violence against him that he
deserved
yeah but i don't believe that you know i
don't believe that's what they're
celebrating
because i don't think i don't think
they're that good
i think they're celebrating watching
some poor son of a [__] get hurt
and that that satisfies something
unbelievably dark in their souls like
the desire to burn the desire to burn
down buildings the desire to melt cars
the desire for the whole goddamn thing
to go up in flames because they're
resentful and bitter
because we can't take these things at
face value right it's like no no you
don't understand you're smiling and
laughing while someone just got his
teeth kicked in no trial no jury
no defense
he's on the ground he's mobbed by
by overwhelming force
and you're celebrating that and you're
telling me that's because of your
virtues
it's like i don't think so
and this is the danger we're facing
right with with this on the on
in all these activist groups i've had
people like that at my
come and protest against me i can kind
of spot them because i have some
clinical training i can i can tell the
guys it's almost always men
and they're always almost always there
to prey on unsuspecting women by being
their ideological affiliates and those
damn guys man the worse it goes the
happier they are
i i wanted to ask you about the
based on your your
your knowledge your background your
clinical
experience what what is the
psychology of this mob violence
when i see it it it
like i i don't even recognize some of
these it seems they seem animalistic is
what i mean
um
no they're worse than animals
they're worse than animals because
animals they just kill to eat you know
human beings they have a twist in them
that makes them far worse than animals
when they really get going well i think
it's i think you really want to know
what i think i think it's revenge
against god for the crime of being
that's really what i think
it's kane and cain and abel it's like oh
abel's your abel's your guy a god how
about if i take him out in the field and
beat him to death
how do you feel about that all my
sacrifices went
unrewarded
yeah it's like
yeah that's what it is at the bottom of
the hell of things
and so you know these people they can
light the whole world on fire and and
that's partly what you're so i i didn't
get your answer to one question sorry
about the potential
warping of your viewpoint because you're
so much in the action like how do you
you know what i mean if you're in that
all the time
that becomes your world in some sense
and
how do you know that you're not
exaggerating the threat because you're
in in it all the time
because i describes
um
step by step
what what what is happening in let's say
this particular antidote of portland in
the summer of 2020 but then i also
followed that up with
certain doubters uh the consequences the
political consequences
say in portland last year uh the city
council did vote to defund
a law enforcement based on the
demands of the radical left activists
those who carried out violence they
defunded police they also abolished the
gun violence reduction team and a part
of my reporting is a crime it's the
crime reporting particularly in the
cities and areas i know what that's like
northwestern united states and we've
seen that we have the actual
data the number of violent crimes that
has shot up ever since the death of
george floyd last year in portland and
other major american cities uh portland
this year 2021 has now surpassed
its
record all-time record for homicides and
this is a direct consequence of the
political decisions that were made by
local politicians
uh in response to
their constituents as well as outsiders
going in
uh carrying out acts of political
violence and carrying having certain
demands over it
okay so that's what you point to
concretely
so okay so let's take that apart a
little bit so
you have an ideology at the core of this
i want to go through this really
programmatically one of the things that
so i'm going to kind of mangle a bunch
of questions here together so
these these core people
it's not so obvious to me that they're
simply left wing
you know because well some of them are
anarchists okay like what the hell's an
anarchist exactly is he left wing or
right wing it's like in some sense it
doesn't matter i know i know ideas
matter that is what i'm saying but in
some sense it doesn't matter because
that person who's decided to be violent
is is working to burn the whole damn
thing down
for whatever reason
you know and and they also describe them
as paramilitary and organized militia
and there's kind of a there's a rat
there's a right-wing flavor to that
right the uniforms
because uniform is more an element of
the right than the left all things
considered and i know that things get
hard conceptually when the
when the opposites touch
right and people debate about whether
the national socialists were left-wing
or right-wing and the answer was well
they were a mixed complex mixture of
both and the worst of both in some sense
although
you know maybe not worse than stalin or
mao but
so and so that also means that people on
the left can point to antifa even the
violent types and say well you know what
makes you so sure they're left-wing and
why should we bear the
the mark of their disquiet you know as a
stain on our political beliefs
so then okay now so there's ambiguity
about the real radicals and it's
certainly to the degree that they're
radical the degree to which they can sow
confusion about their political
ideologies all to their benefit
right so if both the right wing
moderates and the left-wing moderates
point to them and say well your
left-wing or your right-wing depending
on what they're trying to justify and
that screws the system up if they're
hardcore anarchists great you know
that's all the better they just play
into their hands okay and then you you
pat you
you laid out a pathway from that violent
interchange to
policy decisions like defund the police
for example and the pulling back of law
enforcement and then you said well
that's destabilizing cities that's
actually what's happening that's that's
data
and so
but it's not that easy to trace
it's not so easy to trace that back to
the radicals themselves
except insofar as they want to
destabilize right the ideological trail
isn't isn't so clear
so now is there a question in there
well i guess
one of the questions is
is it reasonable to characterize the
radical extremists as either left or
right do you think that's actually
helpful
i characterize them as far left and i
can understand that um there may be
confusion about the ideology certainly
i've
very frequently come across people on
the right who would describe
antifa as uh radical democrats or
radical liberals and that's incorrect
um
i think
what makes me give gave a partisan label
to the anti-fideologists because by
their own
emissions and
their attacks and the philosophers that
they look to it's this
fusion of both
anarchism as well as communism so they
what makes them different from the
traditional revolutionary communists of
previous decades is that
they're not looking for
creating a tyrannical um
top to bottom state communist regime in
fact they feel that communism failed in
part because it was
implemented in that way in
in china or the soviet union
they believe in the abolishment state
and this is where the anarchist side of
the ideology comes out
so that society could be organized into
communist continues
and so they've tried some of these
experiments and many times
last year in
in the middle of the height of
the riots that happened
in seattle there was the capitol hill
autonomous so otherwise known as chaz
when i went up there and that was this
experiment
that
these anarchist communists antifa
uh actually put into practice they
were able to uh force police to evacuate
from a police department and then
promptly took over six blocks of uh a
neighborhood not that far from downtown
and they established a hard border and
in it they actually
took attempts at state building in terms
of
uh
this is where you go to get your food
this is where you go to get your water
we don't uh you don't have to pay for it
this is mutual aid we're gonna do our
gardening in the park um they actually
try to grow fruits and vegetables um
they're very that's actually pretty
funny that's actually quite funny the
garden in the park thing you know
because really that's that's your
solution
you dimwits that's really what you're
doing now okay so let me hammer you on
that a bit so let's say because when i
was reading your book i thought okay
well one of the solutions is
arrest people who break windows
enough of this like when they break the
law arrest them it doesn't matter what
their political background is and then
you think well you know well do you
really wanna i remember in toronto when
the uh the g7 came to downtown toronto
they basically turned the whole damn
city into an armed camp and i walked
down there by the barbed wire and the
cement borders and i thought god damn it
you're turning the city into a prison
and if you don't think you're going to
have prison riots because you did that
you're a fool and so so like i'm not a
big fan of authoritarian states
and so then i might say well is it okay
in the u.s if the state is loose enough
in some sense to allow these
foolish experiments to take place
because maybe by doing so by being that
loose i mean i know the you have the
riots that's not good but by being that
loose it gives us a chance for these
ideas to manifest themselves in a small
scale prove their total lack of validity
and their incoherence and then just sort
of disappear
now the alternative would be to crack
down in some sense more police to stop
the violence in the riots and and to
arrest people who are clearly breaking
the law and we can talk about why that
isn't happening too but so what do you
think about that like is it is is it a
sign of a functioning democracy that
it's loose enough to allow such things
to happen
um i think allowing the stuff to go on
um
under normal circumstances if if
if the protesters or the people who were
somehow discontent had the
self-awareness to recognize when to give
it up but the thing with the these
extremists is that they
they they never admit when they're wrong
they can only they always interpret
history and contemporary actions as when
it fails it's because we didn't try hard
enough
so right last year
the the democrat mayor of seattle jenny
durkin
um she took a hands-off approach to the
autonomous and she thought okay
it would look optically really bad to
send in the national guard to get all
the law enforcement across seattle
county bad
yeah yeah i know
shut it down
let's give them that space and she she
went on cnn in this infamous clip and
she was asked about it she said hey it
could be a summer of love and in some
ways on the outside
we know what happened hey we know bloody
well what happened after the summer of
love
that was the rolling stones concert and
the hell's angels and so forth it's like
the summer of love deteriorated into
anarchy hell pretty much instantly so
that's a fairly foolish metaphor let's
say
okay so she let it go
it's fine so during the day it did look
like a street party and that was when
the journalists were there that's when
you would see the videos and the photos
giving out people giving out free food
um people supporting one another
providing everything that you would need
with creative costs and families could
go in and out freely
but at night is where the true side of
that autonomism came out which is that
when you have no rule of law
true anarchy then
how do you bring order to a place when
there are people who are violent extreme
and willing to kill or rape and so the
course of what happened over the three
weeks is that
in these tents where some of these women
were one woman was uh nearly raped uh
people started fires in the streets and
this was a really densely this is a
really densely packed neighborhood high
high-rise buildings so people lived
there the buildings were stuck on fire
um and shootings occurred almost every
night
and there were six shootings so why do
you think okay that's that's really okay
so that's real let's let's take that
apart too okay so
look we understand pretty well as
as actual social scientists
what happens when it's a summer of love
okay so imagine you put a group together
of people who are only agreeable so
they're just compassionate
and so and temperamentally so and maybe
let's say let's make them like ethically
so as well so not only are they
compassionate temperamentally but
they've built an ethic around that so
all they do is cooperate like mad
well you let one psychopath in there and
all hell breaks loose because there's no
defenses against the psychopaths and
that's the free rider problem now i
talked to robert trivers who's one of
the world's great evolutionary
biologists about a week and a half ago
about the
free rider problem the cheating
detection problem so and that's the
problem i just outlined it's like if
everyone's cooperating
and then there's no
enforcement
the stage is set for
the absolute uh
exploitation of that cooperating group
by anyone who doesn't share that ethic
and so here's imagine this so
women are more agreeable than men
so more empathic
and so that's kind of rough on women
because because the men are
less empathic they're they're harsher
and rougher and tougher and meaner and
more blunt
and so women put up with a lot because
of that because a really disagreeable
man can be quite brutal now
that can be hand homed hemmed in by
other traits like conscientiousness and
etc but we'll just keep it simple for
now
so then why do women want less agreeable
men
that's beauty and the beast by the way
that's the conundrum there right well
because you need someone who's not that
agreeable to keep you safe from someone
who's really not that agreeable
and so men exist and this is part of
sexual selection men exist on this weird
line eh
where they have to be disagreeable
enough to keep the real criminal
psychopaths at bay those are the guys
who come out at night right and then but
they have to be agreeable enough to be
empathic enough to be generous and share
that's a really tight line and it's one
that women are negotiating all the time
and trevor said that no it was i talked
to david buss too
bus said that
young women are really attracted to
dark triad guys they're machiavellian
and manipulative but they're confident
and so they kind of look successful and
they're the risk takers they kind of
have the uh
the persona of daring success
but they're they're they're dark they're
they're they
they border on psychopathic but as the
women get more mature they're less
likely to be taken in by that so anyway
anyways
so this summer of love the summer of
love problem is well what happens at
night
okay so why do you think it happens at
night and not during the day
just out of curiosity you've been there
like what are you watching who's who's
coming out at night exactly
uh there were gang members who were
there and there they were armed uh i
think they took advantage of the little
literal anarchy and that they could go
to a place where there was no police
because there was a hard there were hard
borders that was surrounded
this um
zone so in law enforcement kept away
and so that was just a perfect
opportunity for
criminals to go into
and what what and what did they want to
do
what what is it that it gave them free
reign to do
shootings
okay so that's that's kind of odd so
who are they shooting i mean look if
it's gang warfare you know why they're
shooting each other it's usually guys
who are looking for status who've been
challenged in some way who are out to
prove themselves like there's a good
sociology of that kind of shooting it's
like well why are these guys going into
this free zone
summer love thing and shooting who are
they shooting and why
i don't know the name
but they were untrained and they ended
up murdering a 16 year old as far as i
know nobody no suspect has ever been
identified in that case and how how was
that handled by the mainstream media
that particular event because that's
quite the event
yeah that was then the second murder
that happened at the top of the zone so
then by then the press started to be a
bit more critical because that was
uh nearing three weeks at that point a
lot of the residents were feeling a bit
more emboldened to speak out anonymously
to the not anonymously but unnamed to
the press about what they're witnessing
what they're hearing at night
um i was there one of the nights that i
was there
a burglar broke until a um a car repair
business
and allegedly tried to start a fire
inside but the owner was there and he
had security so he detained this
individual
the news went out and
they had a speaker system set up in
autonomous on with the microphone
somebody went up to the stage and said
that a black person was being held by
some racist whites an entire mob
sprinted to this business
broke down the uh barrier at the
business got in and got there and got
the guy out um the business owner said
he told press later on that he had
called police about a dozen times and he
just wouldn't respond
what'd they do with them
uh the person that got away
oh he got away i see i see yeah it's
amazing they didn't lynch him
oh so yeah
you're talking about the business owner
you're right yeah yeah
it could have become deadly at that
point again this is one of those things
like i'm watching
and i you know i feel so helpless in a
way that i'm
observing
and i
if they start to kill this business
owner that there was nothing i could do
uh police weren't responding they had
already received
uh many many phone calls about that that
incident and they didn't respond
um
but i i bring up the case of the child
it's just sort of like just one example
of what like a real life manifestation
of this
antifa ideology is there's certain parts
that are
you could argue are nice like um
this aspect of community building that i
witnessed during the day was um
it reminded it seemed like a like a
religious community and that they
recognized okay but let's let's let's
take that apart a bit here too okay so
first of all let's not forget that this
daytime utopia
existed in the middle of the richest
country in the world's ever produced
it's like so
we're giving things away for free they
have no cost it's like no no someone
else bore the cost that food didn't
magically appear out of nowhere
nothing that satiates hunger
comes without a cost nothing that
provides shelter comes without a cost
and so this is an artificial utopia set
up by
clueless juveniles who have no sense
whatsoever of how privileged they are
they're so privileged they think food is
free
and you know they're the reason they're
that privileged is because
food is damn near free
and the reason for that is that
we live in a miraculous society that's
made food free
and it isn't because it has no cost man
you think of all the blood that's been
spilled over the centuries to pay for
the terrible struggle that it took us
all to figure out how to do that
that's not free
you know and it's an appalling
indictment of our education system that
anybody can come out of it thinking that
way
so even during the day so you have and
it's the same with the san francisco
summer of love in some sense you know
that could have never come about at all
even to the degree that it did without
there being this unbelievable largesse
and and plenitude that characterizes
modern western societies
so i mean when we see people on the
street even and and i'm not saying that
being on the street is not a terrible
thing but it's a complicated thing
we don't see people who are skeletal
we see people who have enough to eat
and so it's just rubbish right from top
to bottom and and
to think of to have a politician say
well you know maybe it could be a summer
of love it's like what the hell does
that mean exactly our system is so broke
that
violent clueless radical juveniles
can arbitrarily
occupy a part of a city
and in two weeks make something better
really
like what the hell i don't get it now
you talked about optics so let's so
i've been talking to these democrats for
example about
how to conduct yourself ethically in the
political domain and i've been talking
to republicans as well and one of the
things we sort of zeroed in on is this
idea of instrumentality
you know if you're doing something for a
particular goal
maybe almost regardless of what that
goal is
then you tend to use people for your end
and you might say well we have to stop
trump so it's okay to use this person
for that end
but i don't buy that
at all i think there's something deeply
wrong about it you know and so when i do
these podcasts for example
i'm what i'm really trying to do is just
to find out some things i don't know
i don't really have a plan like my did i
have a plan to talk to you i'll tell you
what my plan was it was like well i'm
going to read as much of andy's book as
i can manage in in the time i have to do
it i'm going to do my background
research to the degree that i can then
i'm going to ask him a bunch of
questions about things i don't
understand that's the whole damn plan
and this instrumentality
we've got to get rid of this idea that
we can use people for an end i don't
care what the damn end is and you know
if you and i are doing this right we're
having an honest conversation that's all
we're doing
and that's a hard thing to do
so okay so
back to
okay your answer to whether or not
you're exaggerating this was to point to
the consequences like the defund the
police that sort of consequence and the
destabilization of cities like
minneapolis and portland
and how destabilized do you think they
have become because of this
well they're
in the sense that the
the people who
are dying uh are mostly black and brown
people so
the
um elite liberal class of the cities
don't really they don't experience that
loss of life if if you know what i mean
they may hear the gunshots more
frequently in the streets they may see
distances shuttered or damaged because
of bullet wounds but it's not
it's not people in their families and
their friends circles who are dying
so i in some in some ways they're kind
of
always um
protected from the consequences of
their
political decision-making or political
demands
um i think one other thing about yeah so
if you look at hierarchies if you look
at the way hierarchies work in the
animal kingdom
for example so
even
let's say birds that really don't live
in flocks
they still have a hierarchy and the
hierarchy is some birds have better
nesting sites
and so they're closer to food they don't
get
exposed to wind and rain so much
and they're birds that are generally in
better physical health they're like sort
of
they're birds that are in better
physical health let's let's leave it at
that they sing louder songs the males
they attract higher quality healthier
female mates they have the good nests
okay now a flu comes through that area
an avian flu the birds die from the
bottom of the hierarchy up
and so that's very much in keeping with
what you're describing right is that
as we move up our hierarchies whether
they're based on competence or power
we shield ourselves from stress that's
partly why we actually want to move up
the damn hierarchies and so then when
things get destabilized people die from
the bottom up that's what's the old
saying when the
when the
upper class catches a cold the lower
class dies of pneumonia
and so that's the luxury belief problem
too isn't it is we can have these
adult-painted utopian schemes that we
use to pat ourselves on the back for our
ethical superiority we can fund their
implementation because you talk about
that interestingly in your book right
these left-wing organizations funneling
money into these more violent extremist
groups we can pat ourselves on the back
for standing up for the oppressed and
when things go sideways well it's just
the oppressed that die
so i can't figure out why the left
stands for this you know that's the
thing i can't get is that i thought you
guys were for the working class
i think how this was demonstrated in one
way very clearly was last year uh in
minneapolis when some of the worst
rioting broke out
there was a the minnesota freedom fund
which was set up to
provide jail support uh in legal support
for those who were
arrested and charges crimes related to
the riots
um
the public raised 35 million us dollars
for that bill fund so everybody was
bailed out
and there was millions more to spare
um
kamala here you called them far left you
specifically called minnesota the
minnesota freedom sorry it was mff
minnesota freedom
fund
fund you called i went and looked up the
board members there to see who they were
and you know they're
professional types most of them
community activists some of them lawyers
etc i mean it looks like a perfectly
legitimate site so why did you call them
far left and why do you think they're
not legitimate because that's a pretty
that's a pretty deadly epithet coming
from your tongue given what you've seen
and and heard so is that was that
justifiable that epithet and if so why
i think so because the
the the belief system that's
undergirding that that whole project of
the freedom fund is that the criminal
justice system should be abolished
that is okay that's a strong claim
you're okay so so i want to push you on
that
because i like to talk about specifics
and i noticed that you called them far
left
and so now you just made a pretty
radical claim so i'm going to read a
criticism about you that i found on
wikipedia if you don't mind because this
is a good time to introduce it yes
noes coverage of antifa and muslims has
been controversial okay
that's true and the accuracy and
credibility of his reporting have been
disputed by other journalists yeah well
so what right because of course he has
been frequently accused of sharing
misleading or selective material that's
a little more pointed a criticism
described as a provocateur
and accused of having links with
militant right-wing and far-right groups
in portland
okay so now you talk about the minnesota
freedom fund you say far left and
someone skeptical watching this is going
to think yeah well of course that's what
andy noah thinks because he's linked
with militant right-wing and far-right
groups in portland and is a provocateur
and then you're also a disciple of james
o'keefe the founder of project veritas
which is labeled in wikipedia as a
right-wing activist group
okay so so given all that why should we
believe your characterization of the
minnesota freedom fund
and you know this isn't me attempting to
hook you i
but
but i want to know because
this is the concentric circle problem
right we identified the activists they
just want everything to burn
and so they're nobody's friends if their
sense if they're sensible but now we're
talking about a circle outside that
that's the minnesota freedom fund and
from there you move into let's say the
democratic the left wing of the
democratic party as a whole so this is a
crucial issue
so
you said they want to abolish the
criminal justice system
how do you know that why do you think
that's a reasonable claim well you can
look at those who are involved in
running
that
freedom that bail fund
it's part of this
what was the fringe belief on the left
that
america so from its founding to today so
it's just racism is built into every
single institution that it's not simply
you cannot reform it that what needs to
be done is to uh they say burn it down
abolish this abolish that completely
get rid of it all because it's
irredeemable and unfixable
and
i think that that radical type of belief
that drives
bail funds like the minnesota freedom
fund like the pdx how does that believe
how does that belief drive their bail
fund and what are they doing wrong by
bailing these people out and how do you
know that's linked to an ideology like
the one you just described
because they they believe that the
criminal justice system
targets leftists black and brown people
and so anybody who's charges the crime
uh
that's not a it's not legitimate within
the system because the entire
institution
policing the courts
um judges all of that top to bargain
is white supremacists and whether or not
the individuals involved in it actually
are racist it doesn't matter to them
they say the system is racist and
therefore it needs to be abolished
um yeah yeah you know so one of the
markers for this might be
that real proclivity to use low
resolution characterizations
you know like i've been watching the cop
debacle let's say
and one of the things that really struck
me was
target zero
and i'm thinking
target zero way zero
zero is an interesting number
zero means none
no pollution
well
that means you don't get to go to the
bathroom anymore
zero
you know like everything has a mess and
how about how about some
how about some incremental improvement
in a positive direction you know
you're it seems to me that thinking gets
sloppy and self-congratulatory as we
move towards statements like the system
is broken
it's like well the system has a lot of
parts
a lot
and they're not all broken you can tell
that because you can plug your toaster
in in the morning and hey you put some
bread in which you can also get by the
way and then you have toast
that's that's not broken
and so it's this injudicious
critique
and that speaks of carelessness
failure to be on the ground and moral
self congratulation and it's extreme and
then also interestingly enough it also
speaks to that leftist preoccupation in
some sense with unearned privilege right
because
the only time that you can
get away with thinking that sloppy is if
you're so protected from the
consequences of your own failure to
grasp the essentials of life that
having that mistake doesn't actually
cost you anything
you know the people on cnn who are
viewing the
the portland riots from afar
they're not
having their house burned down they're
not getting beat up in the street so
it doesn't really matter that they have
this low resolution view of it
and so let okay so let's go into the
criminal justice system for a minute
because the americans do lock up a lot
of people
right for a western democracy they've
got quite the damn prison system going
now along with a rapid acceleration in
that prison system there was a quite a
rapid decline in violent crime from say
especially from the 80s till a couple of
years ago and i don't know what the
causal links are there and i'm not i'm
not making a case for a link between the
prison system and the decline in
criminality because it's complicated
but they do lock up a lot of people you
guys lock up a lot of people you yankees
and a disproportionate number of them
are black
and so that's that's a problem that's a
big problem it's like the incarceration
rate's a big problem and the racial
disparity is a big problem and it does
beg the question well to what degree is
the system corrupt it begs the question
of to what degree the corrupt system
serves those the people in power who are
let's say
disproportionately less likely to be
black particularly
and so
and then you can see how that the guilt
about that which is felt really broadly
especially among empathic liberal types
increases the probability that they're
going to turn a blind eye to any
manifestation of what seems to be
associated and even a vague way against
that
and i don't exactly know
what
we should do about it
you know it it's really a co so sorry
i'd like to have your thoughts on those
matters
so i think the vagaries of uh things
that they oppose such as using terms as
like this system um
burn it down abolish systemic racism uh
these things are not defined really
because
uh i think by intention
they never
want their
goals to be reached they need they exist
almost um they being
the radical fallout the revolutionary
problems whatever as um
they need to exist in opposition to
something
so
over and over like let's say last year
all these mayors all these city councils
were giving in to essentially all the
demands you want to
defund the police fight we'll we'll
slash in the budget you want to abolish
this uh gun violence reduction team fine
we'll do that um
you want police to evacuate from this
police department will give you that and
it was never never ever enough in fact
in every time that these uh let's say
in portland the portland mayor or the
mayor in seattle every time that they
capitulated what happened was demand for
more extreme actions was stronger from
these extremists and when they didn't
get that
um
important for example the rioters went
to the home of the portland mayor ted
wheeler and actually set
the building on fire and he ended up
having to move out of his condo
he apologized to his neighbors and he's
essentially in hiding in a way
we don't know where he lives now
in seattle they the robbers so did that
not did that did that not change his
viewpoint in some important manner or
did he feel that the protesters were so
justified that it's no bloody wonder
they tried to burn down his house
like what's the psychology there as far
as you can tell
um
i think after that experience and after
the the mayor of seattle experienced
something similar in terms of people
showing up at her at her door um
uh
they
they gave fewer concessions after that
you know
were
in in the language moving forward that
i've seen
in some of the decision making
pulled back
on sort of the
um
the left the radicalism that they had
embraced in the early months of the
writing they didn't pull back completely
but pull back enough that you know there
were subtle things for example um
like um
the
uh the mayor much more being willing to
speak
critically
uh violent riots that were happening in
his city
whereas before it was okay so it had
some effect
yes there was always there's criticism
before but then there was always
you know this is taking place in the
context of historic racial justice
protests and we can make something great
out of it he he went he didn't
he didn't always qualify his statements
moving forward which i think were were
meaningful uh important in that regard
and but before i forget i wanted to go
back to one thing you know you wrote
from the wikipedia articles
yes yes
and the the freedom fund i know we're
that's still hanging because you called
them far left and now i just called you
far right so who the hell can trust you
so like how do we wade through this
um so
the
i've been
one of the ways
that um
antifa and their sympathizers and some
publications in the press have tried to
de-legitimize my work and my voice is to
pause it or put out this idea that um
because i'm against antifa
uh by default then that must mean that
i'm pro-fascism
so they try now for years
to throw any type of accusation at me
and hoping
knowing that it's false but hoping
that even if it doesn't stick completely
that i'm never left in the same state as
before but it's always that i'm always
dirtied
in a way and the benefit yeah that works
i mean i was nervous about talking to
you it works man it works and believe me
i've experienced the same thing
and it doesn't take much to stay in
someone's reputation right especially
because
look there's seven billion people in the
world there's no way i'm going to talk
to all of them and so
you'll kind of need hardly any excuse at
all not to talk to someone
so you know a little stain will do the
trick
and so this this james o'keefe thing
you're described by your critics as a
disciple of james o'keefe okay
the founder of project veritas a
right-wing activist group
so what's the story with that exactly
well a disciple
would
that was tend to imply that like i've
been mentored or for a long time by
project veritas or james o'keefe which i
haven't
but for the record i i am
very supportive of the work that they do
i think they do
great investiga they invest the
resources money and time getting people
to be undercover journalists to record
things like otherwise you would never
um get on record
um i understand there's a lot of
criticisms uh against and are they
are they reasonably conceptualized as a
right wing activist group
what exactly does that phrase mean in
this context do you think
uh well that's meant to be disparaging i
think me it's probably fair to describe
them as conservative
um in the journalists there
are conservative
but
the what they do is important for
example
they
i thank them in my book because they
provided to me some of the primary
documents of when one of their
journalists found
undercover in toronto city and
and that's something that today
nobody else in anywhere in the united
states has been able to do to actually
get somebody who is completely unknown
located to portland build a whole new
identity persona and get this person
infiltrate the group in terms of the
membership process as much as possible
that type of work deserves
praise not condemnation
um
and
uh i guess the fact that i've been um
you know on record supportive of project
veritas people are trying to use that
just near me i think the more serious
accusations i've been
leveled against me spurious ones are
accusing me of um being
like in bed with violent extremists yeah
yeah yeah millet and right wing and far
right groups in portland okay so what
what's the story there what why
and you know because
you carl jung said every projection has
to have a hook
you know like there's going to be ways
you're going to be smeared that will
work and they're going to be ways that
you're going to be smeared that won't
work and the ones that work there's a
hook right there's something about you
that makes that stick a little better
right and so we all have to examine our
consciences when we get smeared because
you think well
you know
do i have a weak spot that i'm unaware
of that makes me much more susceptible
to that particular accusation and so you
know you said well you're you're a
critic of antifa and that's enough for
you to be labeled as right wing and fair
enough but
like
anything else lurking around there that
makes you an easy target of that sort of
accusation
i'm glad you asked so this really
started um so after i was beaten by
anti-fun in the summer of 2019 that was
when my profile rose a lot before that i
was just a regional small figure i was
occasionally interviewed on fox news but
otherwise really unknown
i think what i noticed after that was
um
so what happened was a few months after
that a local
left-wing alternative publication in
portland called the portland mercury did
what they said was this explosive story
to um expose me they had to interviewed
a person uh given this uh individual uh
a pseudonym
uh today i still don't know who this
individual is like the real identity but
the accused with and provided no
evidence they thought that i
was uh
in the presence of when a right-wing
riot was being planned against antifa
and i i had an agreement
against the right wing brawlers for
mutual protection that was a word this
individual the pseudonymous person said
i was never reached for comment for the
story
and then it was printed
uh on a local blog and then picked up by
journalists on the left who sought to
discredit me such i think there was
daily beasts slay the same places that
have gone after you uh professor
and so they repeated this claim
and
um i had my legal um counsel senator
season's assist letter to the
publication and then they
they just ignored it and the thing in
the us is you know to
to actually win defamation when you're a
public figure particularly against the
newspapers
it's so it's
near impossible so
i felt really helpless and to this day
i'm still really furious about it that
this person who just levied a serious
accusation against me i have no idea who
it is and i have no way to encounter
like to confront my
way well you do have one you do have one
way
the one way is to just tell the truth
yes right i mean yeah that does counter
your accuser and every time that
something like that's been happened
happened to me at least so far
ultimately it backfired
now i mean i'm knocking on wood you know
and i know that you know maybe my days
are numbered in all sorts of different
ways but
so far
it hasn't worked sometimes it's taken a
long time for the for the tide to turn
but it's always turned and so i would
say if you're still feeling rage about
that like one thing you can take solace
in is that
to the degree that you're capable of
representing the truth that is the best
protection you have against anything and
i don't think there is any better
protection against anything than that
they're like the courts anything like
that it's like
no that's when you're playing a deep
game
the only real defense you have is truth
and like truth is reality itself man you
have that on your side it's
it's walking softly walking carefully
speaking softly sorry and carrying a big
stick
so
you know and that that it's interesting
too that you're still angry about that
because
that's a hell of a thing to carry along
and around with you you know it corrodes
you over time that that kind of anger
and
and so it
you're doing pretty good given all thing
all the things have been stacked up
against you
so
i feel angry because i've always i've
gone through my life like i have no i
i don't have it i don't have a criminal
record and i've been arrested i always
i do things right you know i
follow the rules
um i don't support any political
violence and then this persona
um identity that others have made this
made up person of who andy now is
and has gotten many to believe it you
know they
presented this person who's somebody who
you know it's a made up person too eh
because they're pseudonymous
you know that's so interesting they had
to fabricate a person to fabricate you
yeah
um so it's just you know it feels
i i've been wronged in that regard and
um
the evidence i was put out to try to
support it they said there was
undercover video the video they provided
was
me uh documenting
the violent brawl
that happened in everything before and
they said that because i was in presence
in the presence and in proximity to
people on the right that i was with them
or part of them which is completely
untrue and that type of standard would
never be applied to other journalists um
it's a backhanded compliment you know
is that how
well they obviously think you're a
threat
right
right well that's worth thinking about
right i mean that's worth thinking about
because it means you're successful
enough so that people are willing to
generate lies to take you out
and so
i know that's that's that's small solace
yeah yeah we were talking at the
beginning this how many times have you
been beat up doing what you're doing and
why the hell do you keep doing it
i've been
assaulted uh or attacked um
in total four
times uh
two of which were really serious so the
june 2019
most people have seen those pictures
where i'm covered in all the
milkshakes all um
but i had a brain hemorrhage from that
beating so
how that attacks thought is they um
punched me really hard uh
in the back of the head from behind okay
so that's worth that's worth thinking
about okay let's just think about that
for a minute
okay so now you also said these guys
were wearing fiberglass reinforced
gloves
okay so here's the kind of courageous
person who went after you
as they wrap their fists into solid
material and instead of confronting you
face to face like someone who's you know
vaguely civilized might in a in a brawl
situation let's say
they punched you in the back of the head
yeah well that's the kind of person
we're talking about right now and then
we're talking about someone else it's
even more than that is that they've
managed to concoct for themselves
a story about their moral virtue
that's so blinding
that they think that doing that
was justified they've told them a story
to justify that particular action
it's like
anybody who thinks someone like that is
their friend better
start thinking about what they mean by
friend
so and so what's the consequence for you
like you're still doing this how come
uh after that assault i was rushed to
the hospital by ambulance and um
i had a
well swelling immediately that happened
on my face in my eyes i was bleeding all
over bleeding from the ear
um
a ct scan was uh done on me and the
doctor let me know hours later that i
had a subarachnoid brain hemorrhage
which is bleeding in the brain very
serious and i
had about a year of um
like cognitive speech therapy physical
therapy
um to address some of the deficiencies i
had immediately after the assault it's
been two and a half years now um and i'm
still dealing with the cognitive issues
this is what makes me so
angry because nobody's ever been
arrested for it and they these
anonymous assailants some of them uh
took something away from me forever they
you know i have i have memory issues
and um my mind is not the same as before
that's what i deal with but i what was
it like for you going back to your next
riot after you
after you recovered from this or
partially recovered from it i mean
what was that day like you decided you'd
go cover
something else violent tell me what that
was like
i wasn't able to do it for many many
months afterward and when i did it
it was i had
ptsd like this
[Music]
overwhelming fear which wasn't
irrational it made sense as
if these people knew who they were they
would beat me again and possibly kill me
i mean they have been
threatening to kill me uh dozens and
dozens of times on social media or
through emails or phone calls or they
would actually graffiti it across the
city kill landing on murder yeah i've
seen those pictures man so this
incitement of violence was
was real
uh and i went back out and you know i've
gotten a lot of criticisms over it but
um
because i put myself out at risk and
earlier this year in may i was beaten
again when i was exposed
what sort of criticisms
that
you're being too courageous is that the
problem
sandy knows he's being too courageous
man no no it's the right way to
interpret it you know and i'm asking
about foolhardiness right because like
you got hurt bad and so i'm asking you
know how do you know it's not time to
hang up the shingle and do something
that won't get you killed i'm not saying
you should i'm not that is not what i'm
saying but
but it is worth asking yourself that
question and so you did go back into the
fray
so
and you got criticized for it of course
by people who wouldn't do that that's
for sure and they're sensible you know
whatever that means but so why'd you do
it and how did you overcome that fear
man because of course you had something
approximating ptsd and this isn't some
abstract fear like you could be killed
you were damn near killed
so there's a you can do a hell of a lot
of journalism from the comfort of the
computer anywhere in the world however
the further that you are physically
removed from whatever subject you're
you're reporting on
you introduce it's much much easier to
introduce more errors so for example
the journalists who are at uh bureau
deaths and bureaus in dc or new york who
are reporting about antifa in on the
west coast from the comfort of their
their desks in their offices introduced
a lot of error here is for example like
describing it as simply a movement
against uh fascism
um and
i i needed to be on the ground yeah as
if that's simple it's like oh they're
fighting fascism are they exactly how
are they doing that and who are the
fascists and how do you define fascism
and we tried to fight that before and it
turned out to be pretty complicated and
so how is it that they're simply
fighting fascism and who are these
people that think that they're fighting
fascism and why do they think they're
right etc etc etc etc
so
yeah simply that's that low resolution
thinking that
that that really is it's part of a
it's part of a self-congratulatory
privileged blindness that's for sure
okay so you need to be in the fray as
far as your concern to get the facts
right and we already kind of walked
through
why you think that you're not
exaggerating the threat right you look
at what's happened in these cities in
the broader political landscape
let if you don't mind let's go back to
that minnesota freedom fund again
because that was really a crucial issue
as far as i was concerned because it has
to do with these concentric circle this
concentric circle issue okay so they're
they're they're
helping people get out on bail as
rapidly as possible who are the people
that they're getting out on bail and why
do they think that's a good idea
they were completely indiscriminate so
the bail bailed out
people who were
accused of things such as attempted
murder and rape uh one at least one
individual um who was bailed out uh
based on these funds
was
went on to allegedly murder another
individual
um okay so that that adds credence to
your claim that the ideology driving
this is a low resolution critique of the
entire justice system right because you
wouldn't be indiscriminate in your
deliverance of bail if you didn't
believe the whole damn system was so
corrupt that everyone arrested by it is
best
uh what would you call
it's it's just they were just address
arrested for arbitrary and and
unreasonable uh
re reasons
so
exactly um
in portland last year we have
um
sorry a person last year who's accused
by uh the state as well as the federal
government of
using firebombs
to attack police during a riot in
portland an individual who uh
referring to suspect mohammed malik he
went from a different state to portland
allegedly had training in
st louis
uh was recorded allegedly on cctv uh
various stores buying things such as
bats and components to make the fire
bombs he was held on a 2.2 million
uh state uh bail in the state of oregon
when he was arrested after the
investigation that involved the fbi and
the atf
uh that that individual was that that's
the highest they all set out of
the thousand people who were arrested in
the riots in portland oregon last year
the the bail fund in portland raised the
money to cover 10 percent of today's
bail which is 220 000 dollars cash they
put to get this individual out
and again it's it's from this belief
that
these either
that there's no absolutely no legitimacy
to the american criminal justice system
so any act of sabotage such as getting
out violent
allegedly violent people people who
accused of attempted murder people even
acute accused of stabbing people and
trying to kill others all of that uh
they support and help me because they
just view it as one more way of
um
disrupting the system in a way to cause
it to
break apart
okay and so that's that's what justifies
your accusations let's say of far-left
sympathies on the part of this
particular fund and it's the
indiscriminate use of the money
okay so let's go into the bail issue bit
so we could make a counter argument we
could say well look these people are
innocent before they're tried right we
presume innocence
and that's why bail exists
at least to some degree because people
can get on with their lives when they're
getting mangled up by us a justice
system that certainly can be arbitrary
and harsh and
rather infrequently can deliver you know
true justice because that's a heavenly
ideal isn't it and so
so they could just say well look you
know
bail was set what the hell's so wrong
with us putting bail up and we're just
helping people who don't have the means
of fighting for themselves and yeah
maybe they got carried away at a at a
demonstration but people get to
demonstrate and that doesn't mean they
shouldn't
well that we shouldn't help them out
with bail and now you made a specific
point about this particular guy 2.2
million bail right so
if there is any legitimacy in the
justice system that would be an
indication that maybe he went beyond the
pale by any reasonable standards
and so so how would you respond to
because i can imagine someone from that
fund sitting here listening to you
thinking no we're doing this for good
reasons and
so what do you think about that kind of
argument
i would be willing to concede that to
them if they weren't willing to bail out
people who have been arrested let's say
two three four five six seven eight
times within the course of two weeks
when you see that it's used essentially
to get
people out and then they're
allegedly going to riot within the same
24-hour period is arrested again they
have them out again
then
that's more like
it's the indiscriminate aspect there
yeah okay okay okay fine that's good i
want to read something from your book
okay i'd like to talk to you for about
like a day but we're not going to be
able to do it
okay so
uh let me make sure i've got the whole
story here
yeah this is from a section in your book
where you're talking about uh
but really about what led to the ideas
of defunding the police and so forth and
and
about the fact that
if there's any interference
in in a criminal matter between the
police and someone who's black in this
particular case
that the police are likely to be in
terrible trouble for it and you talk a
little bit about the difficulties that
presents for law enforcement officers
who
are at least sometimes trying to protect
black people as well from
violent subgroups so here's some you're
talking about this guy
he was arrested and shot by police after
fighting with cops in a residential area
he had shrugged off being hit with a
taser round and reached inside his
vehicle where there was a knife this was
all caught on camera blake who is black
had a warrant issued for his arrest by
the wisconsin circuit court for a felony
sex crime and other charges related to
domestic dis abuse the criminal
complaint for that may 2020 incident
accuses blake of raping a woman with his
hand in front of her child
according to a police scanner audio on
august 23rd officers responded to the
same woman's residence after she called
9-1-1 and said blake was at her home
again
his criminal history
included assaulting police resisting
arrest carrying a firearm while
intoxicated and use of a dangerous
weapon
even though he survived the shooting the
response was again mass carnage and
looting in the streets of kenosha now
this is the interesting part
not that all that wasn't interesting
democratic vice presidential candidate
kamala harris later visited blake and
said she was proud of him
okay so i'm going to hammer you about
that first because i i want to get to
the bottom of this
did you take her words out of context
proud of him do you think like are you
because this is a pretty serious
accusation
right this guy does not sound good in
fact he sounds pretty much like the
antithesis of good
and if a vice presidential candidate
then visited him and said she was proud
of him and that's a contextually
accurate quote
then well then what the hell which is
really the point you're making there so
did are you being fair to kamala harris
i think so so i think at that time um
she
and much of the public just weren't
aware that this was was
the crimes that he's been accused of or
was convicted of that's his history but
it's that
what we see over and over is
um the context of who these
individuals are who are involved with um
sometimes deadly encounters with police
uh it's almost like their whole their
whole history is irrelevant and the only
thing that matters is that they're black
essentially
i think that kamala and other democrat
politicians
um viewed him as a george floyd 2.0 type
of figure and saw only what was on the
outside which is the black man who had
been shot by police
district just
either discarded evidence early evidence
that was known about some of his
criminal history some of it emerged more
of it emerged later that type of stuff
uh was irrelevant the narrative at hand
because
the kenosha riots were part of riots
that occurred in many other cities
within this whole movement for racial
justice and police reform which the
democrats in my view very cynically use
uh as a campaigning point and as um
as a way to
batter uh the the trump pence campaign
why cynically
you say because you know part of what
i've kind of come to understand is that
some of the stuff is worse because it's
not cynical
you know what i mean is there's a
cynical element and because people act
instrumentally they want to win an
election for example and they think that
they need to win at all cost because you
know look what we're preventing
and i get the malevolence and the
cynicism but it's more scary when you
see that it's actually good people
or people as good as you are as good as
i am that are caught up in this sort of
mess you know because it points to how
complex and sticky and horrible it
really is
so
i mean you know
we talked about the incarceration rates
and the disproportionality of
incarcerated people in the black
community and that really is a problem
you know and it might be a severe enough
problem to bring the whole mess down
right we don't know
it's a real problem
and it isn't going away easily and we
can't even talk about it not not not
deeply
and so then we we fall into these low
resolution categories the kind that you
just said it's like well the justice
system is biased against black people
and so whenever a black person is
treated badly by law enforcement there's
this reflexive move just to note the
systemic inequality and to be on the
side of the person who is a member of a
group that is incarcerated at a much
higher rate than other groups
and so it points to some to a real
problem now god only knows what the
problem is
it isn't a problem right first of all
it's like 10 000 problems and each of
those problems is really hard and you
have to get a high resolution map of
them but
and you know we it
i know why you went after kamala harris
it's because well
this isn't a guy to be proud of
could have she known
or did she just not know
and then you know that's an important
it's a crucial question because lots of
times you could know something if you
want to but you decide not to
i don't think she had to know
because uh
i mean she's a she's a former um
prosecutor herself
she has the resources to be able to pull
up some of these criminal records like
i'm not just talking about things that
okay so that's a good point so she don't
think she did her homework and she could
have done it because i would say okay
look she's busy
like such people are busy right they're
scheduled they are scheduled to the
second like 20 like 18 hours a day
so they're busy and things can get by
them so you say well yeah but she was a
prosecutor and so
she she knows this sort of thing she
could have done her homework right then
and and to go into that situation and
say specifically that she was proud of
this guy it was like no that's not
excusable because you had the expertise
to know and you could have taken the
time to investigate who you were going
to congratulate
and did you you know did you let the
camera opportunity
get in the way
so to speak that's the question you're
raising
okay okay
okay well this is i'm gonna talk about
that particular story with these
democrats that i'm talking to because
you know one of the things i like about
your book
i'm afraid we're gonna have to close on
this there's a whole bunch of other
things we should talk again i guess
that's really the issue
um
you know the devil's in the details
and your idea that you have to be there
to
to know what's going on well there's
real truth in that and you know there is
the danger that because you're there
you're going to exaggerate the threat
that's the danger of being on the ground
and you know hopefully you can protect
yourself against that but uh i liked
your book a lot and i
and
it made me think a lot about how these
groups are structured and
about how this goes out of control
sideways and so
you're doing real journalism as far as i
can tell it
that's not that common anymore
it's no wonder you're getting beat up
you know because real journalism puts
you in a war zone and people get killed
in wars
so uh
i'm glad you're okay
thank you professor you know i'm glad
that um
i'm glad you're back you know the i've
i've been a fan of yours for years now
and uh
the world missed you a lot
we're gone i'm glad you're well enough
that um you you bless the public with
your your intellect i appreciate that
and i
i'm thankful that you took time to read
my book and to give me an opportunity to
speak with you yeah i haven't read it
all yet but i'm going to and i'm going
to try to get some of these democrats
that i'm talking to read the damn thing
too because at very least you know what
you did that i think was so useful is so
imagine that they're pretty concerned
about far-right radicals it's like okay
fair enough and it's not easy to tell
the far-right radicals from the far left
radicals anyways so
but you know by unpacking how these
groups work you you perform a real
service
in aid of stopping the well the
psychopathic radical types who really
are always a threat to everything that
everyone sensible holds dear
you know you shed some light on the
complexity of it the detailed complexity
of it
and that's extremely useful
it's extremely useful to people who want
to know
what's going on and so that is what
journalists should do it's the purpose
of a free press and you know
what would you say
i wouldn't say
what would i say because i can't say
congratulations it's like
it's quite something that you put
yourself in the line of fire for that
it's not just words you know
it's not just words
and and to have and to be brain damaged
from it that's
you know
there are things worse than death and
you got away
intact more or less but
you could have been consigned to
something that would be a living hell
and then to walk back into the fray
despite that it's like
you put your money where your mouth is
man
good to talk to you
thank you professor hope to see you in
the uk
[Music]
you